in the next few videos we'll take a look
at the tokenizers
in natural language processing most of
the data that we handle
consists of raw text however machine
learning models cannot read or
understand text in its raw form
they can only work with numbers so the
tokenizer's objective will be to
translate the text
into numbers there are several possible
approaches to this conversion
and the objective is to find the most
meaningful representation
we'll take a look at three distinct
tokenization algorithms
we compare them one to one so we
recommend you take a look at the videos
in the following order first word based
followed by character-based and finally
sunboard-based